[Musique]
quand on entre chez orange trafic à
mirabel
on est tout de suite attiré par les
équipements de circulation grandeur
nature panneaux de signalisation feux
enseignes lumineuses
l'entreprise est en affaires depuis une
trentaine d'années mais son actif le
plus précieux n'est pas celui qui capte
le plus l'attention au premier regard et
hershey que c'est un équipement qui
permet de rendre les fautifs culation
connectés bientôt les conducteurs de
véhicules connectés seront prévenus à
l'avancé des changements de feu et à
plus long terme les véhicules autonomes
utiliseront l'information pour ajuster
leur conduite
on voit le feu de circulation qui est là
qui est connecté avec un intercepte ça
vient chercher l'information du feu de
circulation
ça vient dire aux véhicules qui sont
auto quand est ce que le feu va changer
dans quatre secondes en 5 secondes il va
avoir un changement tulle ça permet à ce
moment là dans ce bout du monde
la ville de chengdu à leurs ados qui se
prépare déjà à l'arrivée du véhicule
électrique autonome et connectée a
choisi d'équiper ses feux avec cette
nouvelle technologie
la ville de montréal a aussi passé une
commande pour 50 unités
mais voilà pour effectuer les tests
nécessaires à l'obtention de cette
certification l'entreprise a dû s'exiler
en espagne le déplacement entraîner des
coûts et des délais additionnels mais il
inquiète surtout pour d'autres raisons
quand on va travailler en espagne on
amène notre connaissance d'autres
savoirs % veulent partager avec les gens
des laboratoires labo qu'ils vont le
partager avec leur écosystème
puis nous on aimerait beaucoup mieux
partager notre connaissance avec
l'écosystème local permettent de
développer des entreprises ici
[Musique]
une des entreprises d'ici leddartech à
québec cherche aussi à se projeter dans
le futur qu'ici en effet on retrouve
notre prototype de voiture laboratoire
la technologie leader ou télédétection
par laser est utilisé par de nombreuses
entreprises engagées dans le
développement de la voiture autonomes
partout dans le monde donc on peut voir
des six déplacements
l'entreprise développe en ce moment tout
nouveau détecteur longue portée elle a
toutefois dû ouvrir un nouveau bureau en
ontario pour se rapprocher des centres
où elle effectue ses essais routiers
c'est un peu un non sens parce que nous
on est fournisseur on livno techno
techno mais pour pouvoir tester est ce
que les techno vont répondre aux besoins
du client on doit aller dans
l'environnement du client
à l'heure actuelle bien des entreprises
québécoises se tourne pour leurs essais
routiers vers le site de transports
canada à blainville dispose de plusieurs
pistes d'essai endroit n'est toutefois
pas pleinement adapté pour accueillir
les véhicules autonomes et connecté ça
prend des intersections il faut avoir un
feu de circulation sur une piste si on
veut tester des codes usages avec un
vélo avec un obstacle avec avec des
changements de feux de circulation mais
il faut avons le feu de circulation
donc il faut équiper les installations
avec tout ce qu'on va retrouver la
collectivité sur la rue la connectivité
sur les autoroutes bonifier cette
infrastructure l'on nous permettrait
d'être beaucoup plus efficace en termes
de temps passé local nos clients
n'attendrons pas il y ont des cellules
pour rentrer sur le marché donc il faut
que nous si on n'est pas prêts ils vont
aller voir quelqu'un d'autre
mettre à niveau le site requérait des
investissements majeurs le gouvernement
fédéral propriétaire de l'endroit est
favorable au projet mais ne s'engage pas
pour l'instant
blainville est un endroit où transports
canada tu peux faire de
l'expérimentation c'est quelque chose
qui nous intéresse est quelque chose que
l'on veut faire
il ya pas de chercher en ce moment le
temps presse pourtant alors que de
nombreuses entreprises sont engagées
dans une course pour développer le
véhicule du futur avoir des
installations à la fine pointe
permettrait aussi d'attirer de nouvelles
entreprises
ça attire des manufactures partout dans
le monde à venir ici a souvent à
continuer la r&d ici si on peut les
mettre en lien avec les bons chercheurs
avec d'autres partenaires industriels
qui sont son iphone surcroît nos
véhicules
ça nous permet de rester ici finalement
de s'installer ici pas cela malgré deux
fois d'ouvrir une usine maximum 30
après ce but les automobiles de la
prochaine génération seront électriques
autonomes et connecté la compétition est
féroce pour faire leur place dans ce
nouveau créneau et avoir leur part de
dizaines de milliers d'emplois qui
seront créés
les entreprises québécoises doivent se
démarquer rapidement
plus ici hugo lavallée radio canada
québec